hi my name is Ricardo and my name is
Karla the title of our talk is
integrating SQL in the Wolfram language
so for the next part I can get started
but we need to mention that we are we've
been developing this framework with
another person and this is the missing
guy but I just didn't get the reason so
I would have loved to be in here
explaining you might have heard of him
on Stack Exchange okay
so let's start to try to understand how
all of this connects to SQL databases
during the second part of this talk we
will go through a very simple workflow
it's important to mention that right now
the functionality is limited to reading
Galia database so we will will tell you
how to do that there are several
functions to do that one is the
degradation of the connection which is
called database connection then there is
another operation that is called
database inspection that allows you to
see what's into the database and then we
will see how we are mapping the database
to the entities we see some sample
queries and how to deal with relations
and then we'll try to see why we think
that this is really powerful because
allows you to do meta programming and to
generate SQL very easily in a way that
it's really really hard to you know it
will be really hard to write such query
by end and then we also speak about
filler directions so just to start there
is a very simple function that is called
database connection is purely symbolic
dropper is not doing anything once you
evaluate it and it will just take take
several kind of input 1 input is a file
and if it is a file we assume is gonna
be asked you alight another form of
writing it which is something that a lot
of developers are familiar with is URL
specification so you just say something
like my sequel and then you connect over
a database right
now the database are running on my
machine and then there is a full
specification which is an association
that allows you to specify all kinds of
stuff plus database specific
functionalities that you want to to
start the connection with there are
methods to connect and disconnect
manually but usually don't need to do
that you don't need to connect the
connection is done lazily the latest
moment and you only need to disconnect
so let's see how this is work you start
by doing database inspect of Postgres
this will return to you an object that
is inspectable there is a giant
Association of data inside which is the
full schema of the database which means
that you can start inspecting all the
tables and you would see that there is a
back-end type that we inferred that that
column was an integer there is a default
value there is no index the name is ID
it tells you if is malleable if there is
a constraint like is not like if it is
unique and so on okay exactly this
operation is back hand independent and
so it can be performed over several kind
of backends the back ends we are
currently planning to support our SQLite
my sequel Postgres Microsoft SQL and
Oracle DBA and so these will always
return the the same the same type it
will alway address as a string even if
internally is is a bar chart and so on
and there is a plan of course to specify
like the low level kind of time you go
on you can see that this object is
inspectable
programmatically and for example you can
extract you can ask to this object what
are the day bolts that are into my
database so you can say and this
database err just so that you understand
what is going on with the queries we are
gonna do it it's very simple database
that we created for testing there are
Pearson the the end our transaction
transaction from and to people with an
amount a date and we will try to afford
some and you can see that if you see the
foreign keys this transaction it see
that there are foreign keys to the table
Pearson the column that is doing is
called to the other one is from and it's
going to the ID column of the version
and as well there is a there is a nation
foreign key that is where the length
section is open nothing nothing really
be fueled when you do entity storing it
this will create the translation between
the the actual schema and and the entity
so those are now entity properties that
are radically generated the way we are
doing it the convention is this one if
you can scroll down a little to the so
each table generates an entity type with
the same name so if you got a table
there was called person you get out an
entity class that is called person each
column is an entity property and so for
example in this case there is amount
amount will be an entity property that
you can extract out of the type
transaction and foreign key will
generate will automatically generate a
property that will return an entity of
the type of basically the one you are
referring to so for example in the in
person gather nation property and we
will join when you will be accessing the
property nation will get out an entity
nation and on the other hand it will
generate a reverse relation this will be
explained also later this object still
expectable and you can see that those
are all the relations that are created
use the word several foreign keys this
is the primary key and those are the
incoming relations from the Diwan
we also added like a couple of features
for this constructor that we think are
really useful so for example let's say
that you have a database that is he's in
another language I don't know it's in
Italian and inside there is like clear
empty and you don't know what that is
you do the mapping once and you say that
client is customers and so you can
rename the table name and the column
names you know in a way that they're
actually making sense for you most of
the time when you inspect your database
the database administration is coming up
with really creative names and so maybe
you don't want to work with that and we
provide you a tool to you know do some
renaming and the results so I think
someone was asking for this if it was
possible to to store a computed property
inside the entity store so that you
don't need to rewrite the gold over and
over again this is possible too you can
actually do that by for example this is
H squared and you register an entity
function of course this property is
read-only and it's you can think about
it like a database view so you you can
actually create a view that is
completely completely generated by by
other renunciation or or compiled SQL
expressions this is instead a computed
type for example in this database there
is a third person and there is a column
name that is called sex that can be male
or female and this class now generates
you are registering two new entity types
one is male one is female and they are
generated by performing a filter so each
time you are referring to this entity
type the filter will always be there so
you don't need to repeat it
okay so this is just very simple queries
that you can do that connects to the one
we already show before just to show you
that the ABI is literally the same and
so you need to register the entity store
you perform this operation once you do
enter the register of entity store of
the beader was the variable we got
before you can ask now what are the
properties of transaction type and you
get out all those property now you can
see that there was ID from and - and so
you do entity value sorry that's on an
inch okay and this is not reforming the
query directly on my database really you
can also do for example you have entity
transaction one you asked for the date
and you can get out directly the actual
type there is a data object that you can
use in Mathematica so when the database
supports it for example most databases
are supporting it but SQLite so if there
is support for this you get out the
native type automatically okay
so Ricardo has kind of introduced the
concept of relation so relation in
Wolfram language kind of parlance would
be an entity valued property so if we
evaluate personation ID nation ID is the
native column and that is going to
evaluate that that is going to be just a
string which is the true letter iso code
of the nation on the other hand if we
the nation which is sympathised will
have a bunch of entities that that are
then query Belen themselves so each time
we find the foreign key we construct an
entity value and he valued relation but
we also construct the reverse relation
so for example in this case I'm taking
the nation and I want to know all the
persons in that nation so if
expand that you can see that this is an
empty class that is just lazily saying I
want told the persons for which the
national ID is IT which might be empty
we don't know a priori we can perform an
list on it to see what's inside or but
yet the great advantage is that since
this stays completely symbolic then when
you when you ask ask for the entity
value of it then only then the query is
performed so we strongly encourage you
to use anta list as little as possible
at least for SIBO now what this means as
I was showing before is when you are
following this relations you can
basically do sub queries and this sub
queries can be also a lot more
complicated than usual so in this case
for example when I start from person now
I'm going through all the transactions
that where this person is on the
receiving end and then I'm going to the
persons that are involved in that
transaction and I computer age and then
I aggregated by mean and then I divide
by age if some of you have ever used the
sequel directly you will know that this
is quite complicated to write because
when we hide this in a single entity
function these are actually multiple
message sub queries one of them performs
an in-line degradation in a sense so
with this very compact syntax you can
and I will show you later the the
generated sequel this is actually very
complicated moving on so this is an
example that I have kind of over
complicated because there's easier way
to do this but I wanted to show you
something cool okay so let's say that I
want to divide my my transactions into
semesters so what I do here is I
construct with table I construct data
objects 6 months to 6 months then I use
between on them partition and I
basically construct a giant entity
function which with a which statement
inside and so basically you would get if
it's between the 1st of January and and
the 1st of July you get
first semester then there's the second
semester up to six and now that I have
constructed this entity function
symbolically in the Wolfram language I
extend my entity class with it
so that we always have this new semester
property and you can convince yourself
that this is correct
by looking at what semester they end up
in then once I have the extended entity
class I can aggregate the entity class
and you will see that now I get the
count of how many transaction had
happened in each semester but they are
not sorted so I take another step and I
sort it and and now we get one two three
up to six at this point we can do a bar
chart or whatever following follow our
usual workflow in Mathematica now what
is I think what I like about this
example is that we are constructing the
query step by step and each step in
itself is meaningful and we can use it
oh am I getting something that makes
sense or ever made a mistake so each of
those are fully symbolic things that I
can construct with the replace with the
table with all sorts of contrast that
you know they're purely inert they don't
do anything and they compose like Lego
bricks so in the end you will perform
this last query short count the other
ones were just for debugging and this
gets done in one single code to the
database atomic you know that the data
cannot change in the middle of that
query and everything is good and
beautiful going forward okay you wanna
do it just one thing this is not going
to be the way you have to do it when we
release it it's just that we are not you
ready yet it's probably gonna be a third
argument 20 value to get the SQL string
out yeah so then we're saying we we put
like major effort in in try to have like
a consistent behavior across all back
ends this means that we that involves
like a lot of testing and
and and and so that basically we are we
are compiling all those different every
database got a different semantics for
example if you need to do a reg X match
it's going to be different the way you
express it in Postgres versus Microsoft
SQL and and whatever else and this is
the actual query regenerated from a
single very simple select statement as
you can see if you go down when we are
doing something that is that is doing an
ax a numerical operation we are casting
into the database to the right data type
because when you are doing like for
example a division in a database between
integrates the database will return to
you integers this is not the viewer we
think we want especially for Mathematica
user and we want to have a consistent
behavior across all backends and so we
are we have a type inference system and
and we are we are compiling the function
with a type of we're compiler that is
adding casting the right place into the
database function so that then the
actual result is what you expect what
what if you do want to do into your
division right function in the Wolfram
language would be quotient not divided
and that is supported but the default
people are used to is that divided into
integral gets you a rational rational is
not representable in SQL so you get a
real so just to show we were using
Postgres here and so if you are so here
we are doing the full name contains john
insensitive matching and this is how it
compiles down to Postgres if you replace
carlo the entity store with medieval is
not working you need to do ask your
light interior
that message is normal because the
entity were already registered we know
that and now in when you execute it
again you will see that the the actual
query code is a little bit different
actually what happens with SQLite is
that some functions are not implemented
like for example there is no power and
we needed to implement using C
extensions and and basically you see
extensions to implement several
functions and then this is all done
basically by our frameworks directly the
this is very interesting this is the one
that Gallo was speaking about that is
translate to several sub queries and
that's that's the actual code so yeah
yeah we go right rhythm with that to
that we think that I mean some experts
might be good enough to write SQL like
that but you probably don't want to read
it so okay so we have been doing an
overview of all the functionality as I
was saying at the beginning of the talk
we are only allowed reading bragging is
more complicated it's just that we are
already developed a lot of writing
functionalities we are able to create
database programmatically but it's a
matter of design right now and so the
first thing we are going to do of course
is to support insert statement and then
we are going to move to update statement
but basically you can also write like
entity functions and refer to other
columns and so update rather complex
query that there updates to several
conditions we want to support
transactions so that basically you you
execute one query and then you do some
other operation and then you use it to
update and so this is called basic is
select for update and so you make sure
that you are creating a lock so that you
are not creating consistent data we want
to support custom data types which means
that you can have like arbitrary
functions that are serializing
deserializing from the database a very
common example of that is for example my
sequel doesn't natively support dates
but a light yeah SQLite doesn't natively
support dates but you might get a
database from someone who has given you
a piece of metadata that is telling you
this looks like integers but it's really
UNIX timestamps and so you want to
automatically register that in the NT
store to return dates every time you
query it so this is also something that
we are starting to support internally
but we required significant significant
amount of design to expose to the level
of Polish you're used then there are
native datatypes
Postgres ray h store json and a lot of
other things database key migration is
also something very interesting that we
want to do like if you expand this guy
the database we have been using now was
written by us using this specification
so you can see that you can just define
what the schema looks like and this
declaration is backhand independent so
the cool thing about this is that you
can start by defining a schema and work
with a skew a light on your machine and
start performing all your application
logic and test that everything is
working and then when you're ready you
can just switch to another database like
Postgres my sequel on production it will
work exactly the same and you don't have
to worry about all the details like
whether they use numeric or decimal
varchar' or text and so on and so forth
will normalize the type means for you or
another no no no this is already working
we don't yet expose I don't yet expose
this functionality but but we already
work because we need it for testing yes
and for example another thing that you
can do is that you inspect the database
there is I don't know Postgres then you
do what data dump and then you re
imported into another and you get a copy
on another back-end and we also want to
support database schema migration so
adding a column they need a table
and things like that and that was us
[Applause]